kyle and xavier i want to know about the
moment when you left the house okay and
there was a little dust up this is how
the game goes no of course no no i'm
just adding no no i thought like it was
a whole challenge i would have loved to
give you a heads up i respect you too
much as a player if your nephew has
nobody to look up to that keep talking
about my nephew
has nobody to look up to
that is going to figure out honestly
i need you to leave right now kylan
kylen you explain yeah so it's so
interesting because when you leave the
house you have
no vision of what's the conversation
inside so like when i walked out i
literally was in my head like he knows
what i'm talking about so like it's fine
and then afterwards you get out the
house and you find out like oh wait this
is seen as something that is extremely
dramatic extremely taken in a context of
like a disrespectful angle because in
that conversation i even say i'm like
when xavier said like hey don't talk
about his name and i said no like that's
not up to me because i was referring to
a conversation him and i had in my head
i literally was like oh i'm just talking
about conversation in my head i see the
audio i'm like yeah he knows i'm talking
about that conversation
not in terms of because that
conversation had nothing to do with acts
as a person x is a player his family or
anything like that it was all very much
like this is what you and i had talked
about with in regards to that family
member that's what i was bringing up so
as far as when i left i was like
yeah like he'll they'll understand what
i was talking about and then
obviously as i learned in the house as i
learned outside the house
sometimes when you say something and all
of it's not heard or all of it's not
understood you don't have an opportunity
so like i just felt bad because i was
like
after i'm out of the house and learning
from people like no like this is how it
was received this is what was thought
i'm like dang i'm sorry i was glad to
hear that like my friends and family had
already been in contact with some his
family and they were already hashing it
together in peace so that's all i've
been looking forward to do for me and
him just to kind of make sure everybody
knows that there's no disrespect it was
literally
a reference okay you were good with that
because it came back i mean the way it
played out on tv because we only see it
on tv i only saw it on tv was like keep
my name out your mouth that's what it
was almost like um i would say
what he said and how i perceived it
seemed to be two different things and uh
we've already discussed on finale night
that we were going to sit down just
man-to-man have a conversation hopefully
come to an understanding as to why what
happened happened maybe get some closure
around what happened just to get some
clarity and then move forward in a
positive way because every single person
sitting here was a part of history and i
wouldn't want any of that to be
fractured because of a misunderstanding
you know kylan was a big part in all of
us making it to the final six as was
tiffany as was hannah as a big d and
myself we all had a part in making
history and um this is a bond that's
going to last us a lifetime and
i wouldn't want any like anything like
that to be to be fractured without at
least having some type of conversation
so we've already discussed we're going
to sit down chat as men
hopefully move forward positively